faire un petit focus de l'été et on va
bien sûr on est en direct qui a été
d'ailleurs été modifié puisque laurent
ruquier a annoncé avoir été scellé à
salamé qui va présenter seul on va faire
un petit récap et on parle de stars
russes qu'on a beaucoup de choses à vous
raconter sur cette histoire ok
tu es la dernière saison de laurent
ruquier dans on est en direct sur france
2 il y recevait beaucoup de
personnalités comme yannick jadot ou
plutôt jamy gourmaud on sait pas trop
je sens mon petit graphique parce que
j'adore mon cas mais ça c'est le prix
photovoltaïque
divisé par dix en dix ans le nucléaire
augmente et qui dit deuxième partie de
soirée dit ambiance assez des temps de
voir un peu hot faut que déjà elle va
être impressionné avoue trouve super
sexy oui les secteurs chaque fois très
mignon à chaque fois que je viens à
cause qu'on se regarde pendant les
interviews
ouais sauf que sur france 2 ils ont pas
trop de limites et c'est parti assez
loin vous savez quelle est la taille du
sexe le monsieur éléphants est
proportionnel est sûr qu un bambou il a
deux sexes l'argonaute voilier mal an
son pénis est comme un harpon pour
choper la famille et le faux bourdons
qui envoie le sperme tellement fort qui
se fait exploser des testicules et il
meurt d'accord une ambiance tellement
chaude en plateau que blanrue qui a
finit par s'emporter cette semaine c'est
yannick jadot qui sera rejoint puisse
par jan hus bienvenus
[Musique]
ces jauges ont été meilleurs de saison
en saison et ont commencé à moins de 791
me définissent à
856 milan 1890
malgré tout cela bon ok a décidé
d'arrêter laisser la place seul à léa
salamé alors aux petites notes on va
commencer par gilles garder ben écoutez
j'ai votre rigueur votre carte 4
j'irai pas plus haut jamais non mais ce
qui s'est passé c'est que avec les
émissions de cyril hanouna se trouve que
c'est l'émission où il s'est passé des
choses il ya eu de bons interviewé
d'ailleurs souvent dans tpp on a parlé
de ce qui se passait dans cette émission
ça a été animée j'ai trouvé que c'était
pas notre lac ou présentation n'a pas
fonctionné mais j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait parfois de l'âme de la vie du
punch donc je trouve que c'est une des
émissions que peut-être je regretterais
parce qu'à mon avis la manière dont ça
va se passer maintenant à moi me séduire
et je voulais saluer ruquier parce que
je suis souvent des accords x qui dit
mais je trouve qu'il ya une âme et plein
de punch dans tout ce qu'il fait est ce
qu'on sait gilles finalement pourquoi
est ce que laurent s'est retiré il
n'était pas d'accord avec la ligne
éditoriale
il n'était pas d'accord avec l'esprit de
la production a mené par léa salamé qui
était plus journalistique très cadré
elle bosse avec une oreillette pas lui
donc il pouvait pas avoir son
impulsivité il pouvait pas voir son sa
vie habituel ils se sentaient contre 1
et comme ces rues quais quand il est
contraint il s'en va et est ce qu on
sait ce que va faire laurent ruquier la
rentrée il garde des enfants de la télé
oui il va faire il il a présenté des
prime alors ça a été compliqué en
négociation mais il va s'orienter vers
certains prime
notamment un assez axée sur le
divertissement
donc il a obtenu je crois deux prime
différents et c'est pas mal parce que ça
partait mal au moment des discussions
avec delphine ernotte mais finalement
ils ont trouvé un accord moi je suis
très content qu'il revienne le divine
keynote la moyenne mais la moyenne parce
que effectivement moi je trouve que
c'est une émission qui a pris une belle
place dans le paf alors j'ai regardé
souvent quand tu as fait ça fait ça fait
quasiment
10 ans 15 ans qui
vous parlez de laurent de l'émission ça
n'avait rien à voir avec voilà les
émotions avec les polémistes voilà qu'il
pouvait présenter par le passé moi
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup la
petite touche humoristique aussi avec
has qui qui venaient fréquemment chez
lui qui a été découvert ici par cyril et
qui faisait la grosse rigolade la grande
barque avec nous je regardais quand il y
avait ma copine géraldine maillet
évidemment mais je trouve que il a pris
beaucoup de risques qu'il a pris des
risques avec les drag queen qui ont
commencé récemment notamment sur france
2 il a été les seuls à les recevoir
quasiment en télé j'ai bien aimé je vais
regretter laurent ruquier géothermaux
quoi quand il a reçu les drag queen
c'était samedi dernier c'était
l'autopont sa mère si t'es pas samedi
dernier c'était si
[Musique]
si mais même si c'est de l'auto promo il
a quand même pris le risque de recevoir
valade aidera lors une science ont
permis ce rang chef oublié combien vous
oui parce que moi j'adore le malade bêta
9 la warwick et skype avec lui mais je
trouve formidable moi j'ai adoré
l'émission je la regardais deux ans je
sors pas le samedi soir ce qui intéresse
la france entière si vous faites
franchement ce que veut le samedi on
s'en fout je ne sors pas je reste chez
moi devant un plat de spaghetti et je
regarde j'adore passer d'abord c'est
toujours l'actus à la fois la lecture
littéraire cinématographique
théâtrale ses extrémités police en
politique c'est extrêmement intéressant
et moi j'attendais bon parfois c'est ça
finissait 1h30 2h c'était trop un peu
long mais c'est vrai que le duo ne
fonctionnait pas il appuie la covati en
fait de la l'élasticité de des zorra et
commencer à une fois à minuit il faut
une heure pour le coup c'est ingérable
de tapie avait ni la formidable philippe
caverivière qui est génial jean-pascal
vous avez adoré vous l'émission bien sûr
alors moi j'aime pas du tout alors
j'adore laurent ruquier voilà les qui
l'équipe qu'ils ont mais c'est quelque
chose qui me correspond pas en fait je
me retrouve pas et c'est simplement que
voilà je ne sens pas les missions déjà
cet art bon je suis quelqu'un jamais
regardé la première partie est soit
après je m'endors assez vite mais c'est
quelque chose qui me voilà j'ai perso
j'ai vu j'ai partagé les médias moi je
me
[Applaudissements]
bats 12000 sa note abaissée de
montbéliard mais j'ai pas une mais
franchement j'ai pas accroché pour
restaurer la star ac avec vous ça va
être quelque chose ne va pas se coucher
tard avait annoncé sur moi j'ai mis huit
ça c'est pas trop le style d'émission
que je regarde la faim collective qu'on
le prête nom ou qu'on me prête mais en
fait alors même si laurent ruquier il
m'a snobé g genre très mal pris et j'ai
été très vexé ça reste un patron c'est
un patron au crime au but parce que
quand j'ai senti mon premier livre je
voulais faire de mon rêve c'était pour
moi c'est une star on retient c'est
quelqu'un qui est idéalisé toute mon
enfance et je voulais que mon rêve
c'était d'aller faire ma promo dans son
émission battu t'en souviens tu es tu
m'as vu l'usagé qu'il a écrit ma préface
de mon livre est en fait sans le fait de
vainqueur
irma répandue on ne veut pas de télé
réalité on ne veut pas ça et c'est alors
qu'en fait on ne s'était pas sur la télé
réalité c'était vraiment l'histoire
d'une vie ça n'avait rien à voir et donc
ça m'a fait de la peine et ça m'a blessé
mais cependant ça reste un patron et léa
salamé pour moi c'est une des filles les
plus intelligentes du paf et c'est une
fille qui m'inspire énormément elle est
belle elle est talentueuse et c'est vrai
que les deux ces deux patrons ensemble
donc c'était fort quoi et moi ils vont
manquer parce qu'en vrai les deux
ensemble parce que j'ai j'avais plaisir
à mon niveau à moi qu'on prête pas
souvent et ben de les regarder eux
principalement des films moi je trouve
que c'est une bonne émission bon voilà
mais effectivement c'est trop tard c'est
trop tard et moi aussi je m'endors
toujours montrée vraiment
laissé là bas parce que j'ai été invité
la basse et très hâte à vis et s'il a
dormi elle a brillamment passé le btp
vous voulez moi je me dis du mal
du mal sur les pas du père dormait
tu me pose pas la question mais je
m'étais dit aussi pourquoi parce que par
rapport à ce que tu as dit à ton livre
et par rapport aux tirs j'en suis désolé
moi j'ai eu et j'ai eu cette chance
c'est que dans le cas j'aime beaucoup
laurent ruquier j'aime beaucoup il est 2
il est dû à forcément la bretagne pas
loin ah non justement devrait clairement
une petite digue c'est pas grave si
michel huys que je veux dire c'est
pourquoi je l'apprécié énormément et de
son producteur dr philippe lui aussi
mais parce que comme je moi je suis un
petit bonhomme avec ma bd j'avais pas
d'attachés 13 touches de les envoyer
comme ça et j'ai dit si ça vous plaît
vous en parlerai tout et un jour je mets
la télé et il sort comme ça la bd il
fait j'ai lu tout est bon en breton et
ça m'a plu machin j'étais hyper couchée
comme à la classe c est lui qui paie
pour ça tu vois c'est ce s'arrêter comme
ça à dire il n'y a pas de provoquer pas
d'intérêt pour lui salut appuyé l'on
parle donc la règle pour sa déjà je mets
10 / d'ici deux mois
et enfin miko
nicholas krafft
vous connaissez bien moi j'étais déçu
parce que d'abord c'est un animateur de
talk c'est un meneur laurent ruquier et
là je trouve qui s'est perdu mais j'ai
pas du tout aimé lui noster qu'on
sentait bien qu'il était frustré qu'il
n'incarnait pas du tout les missions et
ruquier moi je les aime quand quand on
regarde on n'est pas couché avec des
polémistes autour s'il se passe des
choses où il ya du rythme et là en
l'occurrence on voyait bien qu'il
trouvait pas sa place donc bon il s'en
va l'émission je pense va dévisser
derrière parce que ruquier portait
vraiment cette émission et je pense que
léa salamé va avoir des soucis à se
faire quand vous expliquer qu'on lui ait
demandé de se retirer je ne comprends
pas je cherche partout et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi surtout on lui a
imposé un binôme parce qu'en fait il a
démarré tout seul laurent et puis
l'émission d'ailleurs extrêmement bien
produite par phil thulliez elle est
arrivé comme un cheveu sur la soupe je
ne sais pas pourquoi on lui a imposé
mais dès qu'elle est arrivée on a bien
vu que abandonné il trouvait plus sa
place c'est un exercice extrêmement
difficile que de coanimer en plus un
talk avec des invités autour je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé à ce que l'émission
qui venait avant marché quand même
sensiblement mieux que celle là un
million deux
blessures c'est une émission qui avait
trouvé son rythme mais qui était à
l'antenne depuis je crois de 2006
j'aurais envie de changement après lui
de l'autre côté aujourd'hui ce qu'il dit
aussi c'est que il en a un petit peu
marre de ce rendez-vous de la deuxième
partie de soirée du samedi qui est quand
même rendez vous très compliqué de plus
en plus compliquées entre autres sur les
changements d'horaires très dur de
fidélité rue les téléspectateurs y
l'occurrence rahman légal ils ont connu
que locaux vite c'était compliqué selon
direct oui voilà et puis il y avait
aussi peut-être l'idée de bétonner avec
les présidentielles et législatives avec
une journaliste politique à ses côtés
parce que lui il est pas très
politiquement
on va la laisser à dieu c'était il ya
très chic
mais mais je peux dire un tout petit mot
woods aussi d'ailleurs j'ai remercié
tous nos téléspectateurs d'avoir
l'amabilité de nous suivre pendant ces
deux dernières années pour moi même
depuis plus longtemps depuis 16 ans moi
en tout cas sûr on n'est pas couché sur
un étang dirais que j'ai eu un vrai
plaisir vous allez me manquer merci les
mois je vous regarde ray comme ça moi je
serai dans mon lieu samedi soir bien
tranquille j'ai récupéré mes week-ends
et je vous regarde ray et souhaite bonne
chance et j'ai envie d'embrasser aussi
philippe thuillier toutes les équipes
d'adp elle est vêtue équipes techniques
aussi ici évidemment et ce magnifique
décor et tous ceux qui ont travaillé si
chaque samedi soir évidemment on
remercie tout le monde tous ceux qui
sont en coulisses derrière les caméras
et qui nous ont accompagnés pendant
toutes ces années qui peut être vous
accompagneront encore à partir de
l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
les trois saisons pour rappel de gérard
darmon qui a dit ses quatre vérités avec
le pesnel patron de médiapart ces
grandes ont regardé puis un peu déçu
parce que c'est un homme au départ quand
tu es content médiapart a été a été
fondée qui était c'était plutôt
encourageant ce détient voilà une espèce
de chevalier blanc comme ça qui va qui
va
qui va débusquer des dossiers etc alors
vous savez tout vous savez tout et rien
d'autre je trouve vous alerter les gens
comme si c'était quelque chose alors il
faut lui il faut le prendre au sérieux
mais je n'aime pas mais je je trouve que
les méthodes ne sont pas trés
trés est très efficace il ya quelque
chose un peu tartuffe dans votre
discours qui me gêne un peu
[Applaudissements]
et l'institution reçu deux stars et même
des stars internationales des stars au
delà des frontières françaises
j'aimerais qu'on regarde de cet invité
que le moins hors et nos envies
il faut expliquer que vous avez fait ce
livre avec christophe barbier commence
assure l'intéressé enfin travailler de
fou et c'est d'ailleurs grâce à
quelqu'un qui travaillait chez vous à
touche pas à mon poste que au fond vous
êtes rencontré l'un et l'autre lui a
accepté pour la première fois de votre
source opta dit dans le livre c'est
christophe carrière qui était à
l'express s'occuper de la chronique
cinéma et il a accepté de venir une fois
sur le plateau christophe barbier c'est
pour ça en fait que je me suis dit c'est
le premier ses premiers journalistes
vraiment sérieux entre guillemets qui
est venu sur le plateau je trouve le
livre très très intéressant
particulièrement la zone est
particulièrement la deuxième partie où
faut expliquer ce qui a été fait c'est
dire que je sais pas qui a fait ça si c
barbier ou quelqu'un d'autre mais ils
ont visionné vos émissions c'est ça
allait surtout particulièrement émission
du soir c'est ça oui émission du soir
vraiment pas l'environnement de
l'ontario à ce poste voilà était peu
aussi ils ont visionné plus de 400
heures d'émission est alors en fait au
fond une fois que vous enlevez lui
d'avoir des corolles les conneries les
petites et les conneries que disent les
uns et les autres qui parfois peut nous
agacer ou ne pas nous plaire ou ceci ou
cela mais au fond ça rappelle un peu ce
que faisait aussi christophe dechavanne
à une époque quand il faisait ses débats
avec végétariens sont illégales et ainsi
de suite une fois qu'on a enlevé tout ça
et que on retrouve tout ça par écrit et
je trouve que d'un seul coup ça devient
même très très très mais vraiment ça
serait très intéressant
[Applaudissements]
non mais attendez l'arrivée moyenne et
la moyenne c'est bien ça